son imágenes frente a la sede de la
dirección contra el terrorismo protestan
ante las decenas de detenciones de
estudiantes en Lima el sábado algunos se
afrontan cargos de terrorismo
las han secuestrado a los estudiantes
tamia al del sierra que estábamos
alojadas a toditos durmiendo en años ha
secuestrado no todo esto pasa porque
este es un gobierno ilegítimo cuando un
gobierno Tiene que sacar a las fuerzas
armadas y a la Policía Nacional se
convierte en un gobierno Cívico militar
el malestar viene después de estas
imágenes de horas antes la policía
peruana derribó con una tanqueta la
puerta de la Universidad Nacional mayor
de San Marcos de Lima es la más antigua
de América con cerca de 500 años de
historia fue parte de un operativo que
dejó más de 200 detenidos la convención
americana sobre Derechos Humanos en su
principio sexto habla de inviolabilidad
del espacio académico la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos pidió
al estado cuentas y criticó la detención
masiva de personas cdh expresa su
preocupación por la incursión policial
desalojo y detenciones masivas en la
universidad de San Marcos exhorta Con
urgencia al Estado a rendir cuentas
sobre los hechos y garantizar la
integridad y debido proceso de todas las
personas
la universidad de San Marcos fue
utilizada por los estudiantes como
albergue para peruanos llegados desde
todo el país para protestar contra el
gobierno de Dina boluarte la rectoría
había denunciado el viernes la expulsión
de personal de seguridad y el robo de
sus elementos por parte de manifestantes
el Ministerio Público señaló que fue la
universidad quien solicitó la
intervención